all right today's topic someone sent me
this video this is daniella means she
took to instagram to tell her story
about being attacked by a man with a
hammer
which then broke her orbital bone and
nose leaving her convinced she lost her
eyesight
which caused me to fall to the ground um
on my hands and knees
with blood just gushing from from my
face
means who is a former hong kong rugby
player and power lifting champion in
asia
was out on a walk with her dog in la
when she says an unknown
man came up to her and demanded her bag
and phone
she says she was shocked and said no
that's when the man hit her with a
hammer
and robbed her that's news
but not before standing over her and
apologizing for hitting her
as blood stream down her face okay
if you're unarmed and someone approaches
you with a weapon
and says give me what you got
give them what you have because your
belongings
aren't more important than your life
now she's fortunate that she'll get her
eyesight back
could have been way worse he could have
kept hitting her
clearly this man may have some form of
instability or something
considering the fact that he was
standing over her and apologizing after
he mugged her
who knows we don't know what his mental
state was but people out here
are strange someone comes to me and they
say give me your money they got a knife
take it back yeah i'll be upset yes i
want to keep my
phone yes i want to keep all this stuff
but i'm not disillusioned
my life is far more important
all right the best form of self-defense
is avoiding any kind of fight
all right it's not taking your palm and
jabbing it in his nose and then kicking
him all that
self-defense that you guys get taught
when he punches you
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
want to do a motion like this
to counter and then you're going to hit
the note you're going to use your hips
to hit the nose and then after that
you're going to slow
and then that's it it gives you
confidence
but most of the time
that's it i feel like it's good
i've shown you a few videos
this is what happens when you watch some
stupid self defense videos
you come on the real world and you get
slapped by reality
bro i took some self-defense lessons
this morning and i
think i can take him hey babe you want
to see what i learned in defense class
today
no why not you're a [ __ ]
the hell are you recording for don't
worry about it come on oh my [ __ ] god
you ready whatever
[Music]
how you gonna get my money back ah
remember when there was time box yeah
thai box
game yeah you saw the the advertisement
people was like
oh my god billy blanks is so great i
feel like i can fight
it's aerobics it's not a technique
you're gonna get yourself [ __ ] up out
there do not
take your self-defense class i repeat
do not from tick-tock
from youtube you watch a two-minute
video and you can
getting hit in the face with a hammer
hurts but you know it doesn't hurt
today's sponsor freeze pipe
smoking cannabis doesn't have to hurt
freeze pipes making a unique line of
freezable pipes bubblers bones dab
breaks and more
if you can smoke from it freeze pipe
makes it
the secret is freezable glycerin
chambers that cools
smoke by hundreds of degrees for
smoother and bigger hits
when smoke passes through these frozen
chambers
lift off it's instantly cooled for a
much nicer hit you'll feel
instantly your throat and lungs will
thank you
recyclers are commonly used for dabbing
but freeze pipe
builds this for both insanely smooth
and cold hits go to the freezepipe.com
to get yours today use code aba
that's abba and save 15 off your first
order how about this i'll give you the
best self defense either run
hide or give them what they want or
start carrying their weapon yourself
a lot of y'all just even if you have a
weapon you shouldn't even be thinking of
like all right i'm engaging with this
person
you want to avoid fighting because i'm
telling you
you don't know all the variables you
might think it's just one guy he could
have another person
waiting in the car so after he mugs you
they jump in the car what happens if you
start fighting the other dude gets in
the car now it's two versus one and
you're in a tussle
it's so stupid it's two versus one plus
a car it's too stupid
do exactly like what the cops are
supposed to do supposed to do
which is de-escalate the situation not
by trying to disarming the per
trying to disarm the person oh my god
these videos trying to disarm the knife
the gun yo she's lucky
she's from hong kong she moves to la
right she thinks it's gonna be all sweet
she finds out homeless people overrun
the city and she gets a reality check
welcome to reality
all right there's a bunch of poor people
out there who don't give a [ __ ] about
equality
you're a woman you can get these hands
because i'm poor
and i want what you got
so a lot of y'all just got to wake up
listen i'm not saying i'm happy what
happened to her i'm just saying i'm not
surprised
yes when a desperate person encounters
somebody who says no
sometimes engage in desperate actions so
this is one of those things where
we had that story with the other guy who
got involved in a situation got his ass
beat
now you have this young lady and it's
like it's a lot of this stuff is
avoidable
you know what listen i'll tell you this
a lot of those melee weapons are more
dangerous than guns at close range
actually a knife is does more damage
of course a knife does way more like a
close range
there's more that men than just pop pop
is
usually you have an exit wound sometimes
if you don't take any vital organs
that's
but close close you have the knife and
because you cut it and no turn away and
those and those those classes are going
to be like okay the person is going to
come at you like this
that is not how the person comes at you
with a knife they
they shank the [ __ ] or maybe or maybe
not maybe they will slash but these last
things the thing is
here's what happens right yo you have
all these ideas of what you're gonna do
in that situation you get cut the first
time you panic
you start breathing like crazy you don't
know how to act
and you can't engage in any techniques
that you thought were going to be useful
so it's not even like the other person
knows how to use a knife because they
don't
the thing is once you see it you panic
every time i seen someone get cut every
people i've seen in this scene
get stabbed they don't realize they got
stabbed
they visit like that they just and they
don't even realize they got punctured
and then when they start to bleed out
they're like oh my god and then they
feel weak
so you're not even going to panic
because the person punctured you
because you might not feel it adrenaline
that's right and it's going to be too
late yeah yeah
so it's just one of those things like
don't play
don't don't play and also i'm gonna say
this if you're gonna get a dog make sure
it's not just cute
because i guarantee you she was walking
around with a doberman that [ __ ] would
have never run up on her
you know what i'm saying hey yeah you
want a poodle trying to look cute in l.a
oh pluto getting slashed too you don't
look cute with that orbital bone we're
making sausages tonight
okay come on now what middle worldwide
you should have got a pimple yo listen
stop playing i'm just i'm just saying
stop playing she was with her dog and
this man was still bracing you know
that's a tiny dog guys
and she lives in la that's like times 10
odds
guys vegas i'm winning my money stop
playing i'm beating the spread they're
beating odds
guaranteed los angeles landslides
getting mugged she says no you know
shibushi listen if you grew up in a bad
neighborhood someone comes up on you on
a weapon
you're giving them what you got but you
kind of feel it what you mean you know
what [ __ ] run up on you
when you around danger don't you know
when you're around angel you kind of
feel you want to hear something [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm about to give you money
yo yo yo yo yo story time with abba
goddamn
hit the goddamn patreon this one is good
it might be funny and everything and
stuff
but it's not a joke no okay you you
cannot just take my belong
brev they will take it they'll take him
and people
in need them they value your belongings
over your life you understand what i
said
they're in a situation where they need
your belonging into to continue into
existence
they value your belongings more than
your life
okay they don't they don't care they'll
stab you
they'll punch you they'll shank you
they'll shoot you
give it up that's right give it up give
it up like look at you now you're
bleeding you ain't got no more eye
yo it ain't it's not a joke and all
those videos about self defense
if you want to go into that round take a
proper proper class and even then
it doesn't guarantee you nothing that's
all i got to say
foreign
[Music]
ciao